or fall out for the biden administration
after saying it's got total confidence
in general mark milley remember the new
book claiming the general called china
to undermine trump and so far nobody is
denying that the calls took place
the key now is to find out what was said
and republican lawmakers are demanding
answers
and for you to go and have the call with
the chinese there's nothing wrong with
that for you not to tell the president
that you had that call with the chinese
and for him not to be aware that's the
problem is because you want him to be
all informed and at his best to proceed
you don't have the back of the chinese
you have the back of your president if
in fact that is true
then those would be individual counts of
insubordination and the appropriate you
know action would be you know court
martial proceeding he actually told the
chinese hey if we're going to do
something we're going to give you a
heads up
i mean that is so unconstitutional so
wrong
and republican senator john kennedy
suggesting biden might scapegoat millie
to distract from his afghanistan failure
i know president biden has said he will
stand behind and stands behind general
milley
and maybe that's true for the short term
but i'm going to give you even odds that
eventually
the white house throws him under the bus
because the white house desperately
needs someone besides president biden on
which to blame the the stunning
incompetence in afghanistan
let's hear a prediction judge does
millie
skate on this or does he get canned you
know i i don't i don't have the
slightest idea but what i can tell you
is this if things get really bad if the
coronavirus i mean if they can't get
more people vaccinated the economy's
going to to
can i say it and um you know
afghanistan's a mess we're leaving
americans behind the border's a mess
inflation's a mess i mean somebody's got
to go if anyone goes he goes look and i
wouldn't be sorry to hear him going
because apparently there's only two
people who can give him permission to
call his chinese counterpart assuming
that he said what what uh woodward is
saying he said and that is the president
or the acting secretary of defense which
was a sky miller and uh both have said
we didn't give him permission to do that
so you know it's all about civilian
control over the military i don't like
him responding to nancy pelosi's calls
where she's screaming after january 6.
he gets his uh whities in a in a uh in a
tizzy and he decides he's going to go to
everybody who's involved in the nuclear
uh weapons uh uh
issue and he's going to tell them come
to me first since when do they come to
you first you go to the president first
yeah nancy pelosi is not in the chain of
command all of a sudden she is richard
how'd that happen
i i i can't speak to that but that's the
topic
no i mean the topic is whether or not i
know but that's a part of the story
speak to it richard
the floor is yours only in your mind uh
but i think we should work on actually
getting all the facts before we just
jump to conclusions number one why would
we do that well cause we're the news
maybe yeah we're commentary
but number one anytime a book publisher
is releasing a book what they do is they
find the most like salacious lines of
the book and they release them out so
people like us can chew over them and
because our politics has become so
absolutism so people like the
politicians that we just saw there most
of them will likely be twenty twenty
four million
didn't deny it because he's not he's
that he's doing his job he's not gonna
deny he's not gonna get in the weeds on
this his job is to run the military so
what you have is to advise the president
what you have here what you have here is
a line released from a book right that
was clearly sensationalized and then you
have actual journalists reporting like
our very own jennifer griffin who
reported that number one this call
didn't happen in secret number two the
first call that happened with the
chinese general and uh with millie
involved was a call that was initiated
by this defense secretary esper uh so
before we get into this and we also had
our very own jack keane who talked about
this and says before we jump let's get
all the facts number one and let's not
call for transcripts because many times
when these calls happen they happen in
secret because they could be talking
about a lot of things and when this
stuff gets gets released out to the
public we destroy the back channels that
we have between us and other foreign
governments especially foreign
governments that we we have bad
relationships with because you don't we
want to be able to do the ukraine
obscure
the ideal of us going to nuclear war
with them that is that is the pentagon's
uh
opinion dana um
do you think when woodward and costa
reported this that maybe they got a leak
of the transcript do you think someone
told them who was on the call exactly
what happened it's not like they would
make something like this up
okay well
all right well
i don't know if there's a transcript i
don't even know if there are transcripts
of those there might be transcripts at
the defense department i don't know how
that works um
i would doubt that they got a transcript
i would imagine that this was a
description of what was happening in
general it's because actually the
accusation is quite general and that's
why we're saying well we could we get
the facts to find out
what was said and then what was the
chain of command so did the secretary of
defense know or did the secretary of
defense's deputy know is that good
enough i don't know i will that he'll
have to answer that as well but i also
wonder about this because
costa and woodward are not just any old
authors like somebody who wrote how i
saved the world everything would be okay
or the plus okay nothing in the books
that we write don't panic it's actually
news it's actually breaking news
these two are well especially costa he
is a reporter for the washington post
general milley is the
in the office of the joint chiefs he is
advising a president as we speak trump
and then biden so
if if this is if this guy
is usurping the commander-in-chief
that's big news and that should not be
held
to have a one-line leak to sell a bunch
of books for us to then find out next
week that actually it was all nuanced in
context doesn't actually allow us to
ruin this guy's life so i'm i'm i'm
skeptical about it uh i'm not saying it
didn't happen i just don't know and i'm
curious about
how comfortable the authors are that
this is happening and if you're joe
biden you can't trust this guy milly now
well i don't know if he knows what's
going on i mean oh yeah i do enjoy the
cognitive dissonance in people
who could just easily reverse this say
it's a general going around joe biden's
back because he believes that the mental
decline has become so so serious that
we've got to do something uh the people
that would be defending millie right now
would be condemning millie so you have
to like step by step back and do kind of
like a comparison we have impeached for
less you know the phone calls we've
already had two phone calls under joe
biden we've had the call to the afghan
president to instruct him to lie i'm
sure there was nuance to that milli to
china oh they're a little bit dif you
know
do we know what was on the on behalf of
our country or was on behalf of
something else not perfect phone calls
not perfect phone calls
milly is a symptom
of the emotional spasm that went on from
2016 to 2020. it wasn't the americans
who were having the spasm it was the
media the people in power it caused him
to overlook a virus that was spreading
out of china it caused him to overlook
riots in looting across the country a
concerted effort to disqualify law
enforcement all because they hated this
guy who had mean tweets and made mean
jokes who was an outsider calling bs on
all these people right so this is about
getting rid of the most dangerous
president in world history the one you
know who removed the threat of north
korea from the table who ushered in
peace in the middle east the abraham
accords who helped operation warp speed
begin get off the ground and didn't take
a paycheck
didn't take a picture and yet adults
adults like millie have deluded
themselves into thinking that this guy
would invade china that's this is that's
what this is about it's about how do you
know that
it's part of the story china's concerned
china called and said we're concerned
about trump i'd say screw you you better
be there there weren't any facts with
russia collusion and you guys ran with
that forever hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else